Welcome back everyone
Good news
Marvel finally did the thing
They finally listened to everyone
and just made some huge really good changes
to Daredevil born again after the shellacking
they've been taking the last year.
They needed a big win, and it looks like they finally
chose the path of sanity with the new Daredevil show.
So we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel, of course
I'll do episode videos for when it does release.
Vincent D'Onofrio was just doing Kingpin
Press for the Echo series.
He said they were about to start
filming Daredevil Born Again episodes again.
know, Kingpin is back for sure,
and he's going to get what he wants, like romance.
That's what's going to happen.
when he says Kingpin is going to get what he wants,
he's talking about Kingpin
becoming mayor of New York City.
I'll get into that later in the video
because that's more about the Echo Post-Credits scene
in how they're setting up Daredevil born again
inside the MCU.
the amazing news you probably just saw
in your feeds recently is that Marvel completely
changed some fundamental parts of daredevil born again
last year.
Kevin Feige
These are the episodes they've been filming.
Pulled the plug Took us a while to find out what could
have been so bad about the situation with the show
that he would fire the former daredevil born again
writers in a showrunner and hired the writers
from Punisher Netflix in the Loki series
to completely rework the show from the ground up. ba.
Baskin-Robbins always finds out.
And now Foggy Nelson and Karen Page are coming
back to the show alive, maybe with a few extra
city miles on them because the new show picks up
after the five year time jump in.
After a few years of everyone in the MCU
being blip back.
we're talking like the year 2026 inside the MCU.
they're apparently some pretty big reasons
why Kevin Feige put
the kibosh on that original version of Daredevil
Born again last year.
Some story based reasons in some practical reasons,
more to do with
how Marvel is actually physically making
and releasing new TV shows on Disney.
Plus.
like everything about the way they do TV
shows just change.
But the thing is, is that the shows
that get the benefit of all those good changes
start with Daredevil, Born again.
see won't really see those changes until Daredevil
Born Again starts next year.
really good example of that is Echo.
Like Echo was made on their old system of the way
they made TV shows in the past.
Like you didn't get the benefit of all the changes
they made last year,
But apparently in the original version of Daredevil
Born Again, they were going to start the show
in episode one with Foggy Nelson and Karen Page
being dead, having been killed prior
to the events of the show, they'd already revealed
both Daredevil and Kingpin did not get it.
Now, that was a big plot point during Echo.
I think part of the idea
is that originally both Karen and Foggy
did get snapped by the nose during Avengers
Infinity War.
Matt tries to pick up the pieces
and make it through the five year time jump
without them continuing to be daredevil,
taking out criminals, cleaning up New York City.
still a little less stabby than Hawkeye
when he was in full ronin mode.
But similar vibes like doing similar things
during the five year time.
Jump, Kingpin uses the chaos going on around the world
during that five year time jump
to seize all of this power back that he lost
when he was arrested during Daredevil Season three
and becomes more powerful than ever inside the city
during that five year time jump.
I just talked about it in my big Echo video.
But during the Echo series,
they revealed in a flashback
when they're in the middle of the five year time jump,
the New York City cops
were so terrified of him,
they basically let him do whatever he wanted,
Like he straight
up walked through the police
and just joined echo from them.
Like, No, you're not arresting
her. I'm taking her right now.
And they let him do That's how powerful
he was meant to be during the five year time.
Jump in. Remember,
a lot of time has gone by since then.
So apparently, when he got arrested
at the end of Daredevil season three,
he did not stay in prison that long
and he didn't really lose that much of his power base
or it didn't take him long to rebuild it.
then when Avengers Endgame happens,
the Hulk snaps everyone back.
Foggy and Karen would have also come back to
but apparently something was supposed
to happen to them, like they get killed by kingpin
somehow as retaliation
for the events of Daredevil season three
because Kingpin had to wait for them
to get snapped back to kill them.
To actually hurt Matt.
like killing Foggy
and Karen was worse than killing Matt himself
because now he has to live with the knowledge
that he couldn't protect his best friends.
And it was supposed to haunt him through the events
of the original version of Daredevil Born Again
before Kevin Feige canceled
and had them rework everything.
the brand new showrunner from Punisher.
Netflix in the Loki writers apparently completely did
a brand new version of episode
one like Up totally different
they took about six episodes worth of footage
that they'd already shot on Daredevil board again,
completely reworked that like shot
a bunch of extra footage to fit in and changed things.
That happened during those episodes then shot
two more brand new episodes
that were completely different
from what their original plan was.
So there's still be nine
episodes in the first half of Daredevil Born Again
Season one, but apparently in the original version,
like the version that they canceled,
Matt was not going to wear the new daredevil suit
or any daredevil suit until episode four.
He was going to have his own Tobey Maguire Spider-Man
No more kind of moment like Spider-Man two,
where he throws away
the old daredevil suit like chucks it in the trash.
Then by episode four,
he's finally inspired to put it back on again.
it sounds like originally their plan was to kill off
Foggy and Karen Mosley
just to create more drama and conflict
at the beginning of the season.
Like give Daredevil more of a reason to hate Kingpin
if that were even necessary
or hate other villains during the season,
if it was going to be another villain killing them.
however that went down, Kevin
Feige was just totally not cool with.
It was like, No, no, no.
Quality control, boom, stop right now.
We're going to completely redo all this stuff.
apparently it was actually the strikes
that basically forced everybody
in Hollywood
to go on break for a large portion of last year.
during that, Kevin Feige watched the episodes
that they'd already been filming on Daredevil
Born Again, and that's when he decided
to cancel everything and completely reworked the show.
it almost makes it sound like
he hadn't actually been watching the episodes.
They'd been filming like the dailies up
until the strike actually happened.
Like, Normally you would expect them to be spending
way more time on the series
while they were actually making it.
I've heard again, a couple videos about this
in the past, like it's part of the bigger changes
at Marvel where they basically pulled
way back on their output, like they slowed everything
down, delayed
a lot of the movies that are happening in 2024 to 2025.
So they had more time for quality control.
one of the reasons they did that.
One of the biggest problems they had is that Disney,
the powers that be, were basically forcing them
to release a ton of TV shows in a ton of movies
every year.
Like what if every movie?
What if every TV show could be a marvel TV show?
obviously the answer is no.
Kevin Feige only has so many hours in the day
that he can actually do quality control,
and it turns out he is the secret sauce that actually
makes a lot of the stuff that they do really good.
So if you wonder why Secret Invasion, for instance,
was so chaotic, like so all over the place,
like there were a couple of good moments,
it seems like they had the bones
of a good show in there, but it just did not work out.
Like the execution was terrible on that show.
a lot of the reason for that is because Kevin Feige
didn't have the time
to actually pay attention to what they were doing
while they were actually filming it.
He had to delegate a lot of that to other people.
They just weren't able to do what he normally does.
thankfully, all that's changed
and they've completely changed the way
that they actually make the shows
and released them now.
Now it's way easier for them to do this
kind of quality control
they've also structurally changed
the way that they release the shows.
So now it actually works a little bit
more like actual television
and not just like one long movie
that they chop up into like six different pieces.
That's basically meant to solve a lot of the pacing
issues that they've had on most of their shows.
Like one of the bigger complaints about Echo
is its pacing issues.
I just did a video for the Echo Post-Credits scene.
It's meant to be a date of a born again
teaser directly setting up the series, so I'll link it
at the end of this.
Basically Kingpin
getting the idea to run for mayor of New York City.
supposedly in the new version of the show,
he might start the show already being mayor.
But Foggy and Karen are back in the live.
Jon Bernthal Punisher was meant to be a core main
character in the original version
of the show Season one is supposed to be eight
episodes, just divided into two different parts.
So he might just be a main character
in one of the Arcs, but not both of them.
some of the other Marvel Netflix defenders
characters might show up in other story arcs.
Maybe not the first arc,
but like other arcs in the future, are they
literally just canonized
all the Marvel Netflix shows to the MCU.
I've already done a couple of big videos
about that too, so I'll link then down the description.
Really happy
that they finally acknowledged all that stuff.
the brand new main villain outside of Kingpin himself
is supposed to be news from the Daredevil comics.
He has special powers,
but he's not a mutant in the comics.
They could change that on the TV show,
or they could just change the way his powers work.
So they seem a little bit
more on the level of daredevil sensory powers.
Like Daredevil got into an accident
that gave him abilities, sensory based abilities.
so he's more of a mutate, not an actual mutant.
in order to be called
a traditional mutant, you actually have to be born
with your powers, with the x gene.
muses ability lets them become almost imperceptible,
even to people with daredevil's level of senses.
So it's sort of like a reverse version
of Daredevil powers.
His body is able to draw on every bit of sensory
information around him.
so Daredevil, other heroes have a hard time tracking
his movements during fights or spotting him in crowds.
he's also got superhuman strength and speed.
But it's not like quicksilver's speed.
His speed only works in short bursts.
it is also an expert fighter.
So Daredevil absolutely hates him.
He's a relatively new villain.
They just introduced him in the 2016 Daredevil Volume
five run as part of an Inhumans crossover
storyline with Daredevil for everybody wondering
what they're going to do with Inhumans in the MCU.
Now we did see Black Bolt
come back during Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness.
So they're canon to the larger multiverse,
But they haven't really said
what their plan is for Inhumans inside the main
MCU universe.
Basically, when the story picked up, news was killing
a bunch of Inhumans
and turning their bodies into gruesome art.
Daredevil found one of his crime scenes,
and he just kept doing this all over the city.
wall Daredevil is supposed to be fighting news
during Daredevil Born again
Kingpin was supposed to have run for mayor
on an anti vigilante campaign
secretly using the police in the press
to actually try and get rid of heroes
like Daredevil, Spider-Man, Punisher,
the other Netflix defenders characters.
already
you longtime daredevil Netflix fans will remember
he did this all the time
during the Daredevil Netflix series.
He would always try to pin murders on Daredevil,
discredit him in public during Daredevil Season three.
He even put Bullseye in the Daredevil costume
as part of this whole plot
I think part of the idea
is that by the time we get to Spider-Man four, Kingpin
is still mayor of New York City And just like he did
during Daredevil Season three with Bullseye,
he might hire Spider-Man villains
to go after Spider-Man in Daredevil.
inside the MCU.
You can actually make Kingpin the person to hire
and put together a version of the sinister Six team to
For a little while, I actually thought that he was
going to be the one to actually buy the Avengers Tower.
they can always tease that during Daredevil born again
but they might see bigger stuff like that
for Spider-Man four,
like some stuff they will save for the movies.
but either way, it does sound like Kevin Feige
Marvel are finally listening to the fans,
like Take the path of Sanity,
bring these characters back.
Thank you so much.
Let me know in the comments.
Where do you want to see the other Netflix defenders
characters show up
if they're not going to show up
in the very first daredevil born again arc?
Remember, I think we're supposed to get up
to two seasons of the show, but
it'd be like 36 episodes
total spread out over a couple of years.
So they'll be like a couple more years.
A brand new daredevil show.
It could go beyond that, though.
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
I just did that echo Post-Credits scene video.
Click here to watch that, learn
what's going on with Daredevil Born Again
and click here for my new Deadpool
3 teaser trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
And I'll see you guys in the next one!